[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today casy is
with us in Amarillo Texas to start this
hour hi Casey welcome to the Ramsey Show
hey Dave and George how are you better
than we deserve brother what's up well
I'm a little embarrassed because this is
really going to Showcase my ignorance of
the subject but I've got a few questions
about the national debt I don't know if
I don't know if you've heard but we are
in debt a little bit I heard the rumor
yep so I've got three questions for you
okay the first one is who do we owe this
$33 trillion to the second one is why as
a country did we borrow it in the first
place and the third one is is it even
possible or logical for our federal
government to pay off this debt and
operate debt free those are great
questions um well who we owe the money
to or whoever bought the treasury bills
are called tea bills and the treasury of
the United States issues a
bond and if you buy that Bond then that
means that if I bought a I don't know
$100,000 treasury bond that means the
United States of America owes me
$100,000 if I bought that Bond and it
pays me a certain interest rate now I
know they're never going to pay the bond
uh or if they do they're going to pay it
by issuing another
one yeah okay which is if it actually
ever does come due that's how they do it
they'll issue another set to cover the
ones that are coming due but I also know
that I can sell that Bond at any moment
because the uh the credit rating of the
United States of America is still strong
okay so that's how they finance it and
the danger is when foreign countries or
uh foreign entities of any kind wealthy
uh corporations in foreign enti in
foreign countries buy up a bunch of that
that means the United States is in debt
say to China
example deeply in debt to China it's a
little dangerous uh politically uh but
it's not like they can call the debt
it's not like they can repo Kentucky so
it it's you know it's okay so but um in
that sense it's not dangerous but it's
just kind of creepy you know what I'm
saying so your second question was can
or your third question was can we ever
pay it off your second question was
what why did we go in debt well we went
in debt cuz just cuz like normal like
regular beings they spent more than they
made when the revenue coming in from
taxes and other things won't cover the
expenses of Highways and Military and
$45,000 toilet seats and a billion
dollars to this country and8 billion to
that country in
supplies um which we do pretty regularly
we give billions and billions and
billions away overseas when we don't
have the income in a year the amount
that were short Revenue
is sure is not enough Revenue to cover
the the outgo the budget the difference
is called the
deficit and uh the amount that we borrow
has gone up every year because we keep
going F we keep uh spending not just
spending more than we make but every
year spending more than the more than we
make we raise the amount that we're
going into thatt so when they say they
cut the deficit all that means is is
they didn't go over budget quite as much
that's all it means
means you know so it's kind of it's kind
of an oxymoron on Words and then the
last question is can we uh get rid of it
mathematically we could I don't think we
have the political um willpower to do
it because as soon as you tell
um your Uncle Henry who gets
a A subsidy because he runs a dairy farm
from the US government that he's not
going to get that subsidy anymore
because we're cutting our expenses that
he's not going to vote for that
congressman and that congressman's going
to get get replaced by a congressman who
will spend money like he's a drunken
Congressman right yeah and so the people
won't they don't they they want to they
they in theory a lot of people say I'd
like to balance the budget I'd like to
get the the income to at least equal the
where we're not going further in debt
but to do that would require cutting a
lot of things out and the problem is
we're so far in now that a big portion
of the budget is just the interest on
the old
debt right and you can't cut that you
got to pay that so where are you going
to cut you're going to cut giving um you
know money in the Middle East money in
the Ukraine uh money to this country
money to that country there's a lot of
people talk about that uh are you going
to cut the military I mean those people
don't get paid anything anyway and they
put their lives on the line for us I
don't know how to do that uh it just
requires this
tremendous um the amount
of hate that it would generate because
of the number of lives it would touch to
cut everything necessary to cut to get
it down to balance would I don't know if
anybody's got the political Capital to
pull that off either side I think it'd
be the be the last time that party
existed uh right now cuz people have
gotten used to being on the government
Dole one way or another you know they're
used to the the local government in my
county is waiting on $14 million right
now to build build a highway or to redo
a road that runs up beside one of my
houses and they've been waiting 5 years
on that $14 million from the federal
government and they won't build the road
until the $14 million comes meanwhile
the road's a damn damn goat track you
know it's awful but but but every and so
they're waiting on $14 million from the
government instead of the local County
handling their own business wow and that
it goes that it's that way everywhere
times thousand you know waiting on
waiting to do the bridge repairs until
we get the the government money waiting
to do this until you get the government
and so everybody's on the dead gum take
and nobody wants to say no and saying no
is the only way you balance a budget
when you do it at home casy when I do it
at home the way I live on less than I
make is I look at the kids and I say no
I look at my wife and look and we look
at our budget and we go we can't go on
vacation we're broke people we got to
not be broke people before we can go on
vacation we can't afford that car uh
those bass are going to get away cuz I'm
not going to have a bass boat with a
motor that bit because I can't afford to
pay for it this is what normal people do
we say no but the federal government has
absolutely no ability to say no because
everybody wants them to say yes yeah so
that's the problem it's not a math
problem you could actually cut taxes and
revenues go up art laer proved that
under Reagan it's a statistical fact
it's not a political Theory so it
actually worked the reeven you see
Warren Buffett's method to solve this
yeah great quote absolutely yeah I said
I could end the deficit in 5 minutes
minutes you just pass a law that says
anytime there's a deficit of more than
3% of GDP all sitting members of
Congress are ineligible for reelection
there you go you lose your job unless
you fix this yeah there's one way to do
it because you redefine what winning
looks like what does winning look like
as a congressman now given everybody
free money and if you made it what win
the only way you can stay is if you
balance a budget that's a new way of
saying what winning looks like hanging
out with Lobby they would learn the new
ancient word the ancient word
no no you press your tongue towards the
roof of your mouth you release and let
air go by no create your free every doll
budget today the simplest way a budget
for your life